Paris Jackson defends going topless  [Music]  Michael Jackson's daughter took to  Instagram Friday to address her stance  on nudity after receiving some backlash  for posting a risque shot while  sunbathing in the nude with her dog  Paris clapped back at the haters by  posting another pic showing a little  less but still topless smoking a  cigarette on her balcony captioning the  pic in part being naked is part of what  makes us human not only is your body a  temple and should be worshiped as so but  also part of feminism is being able to  express yourself in your own way the 19  year old aspiring actress and model also  revealed she's usually naked when she  gardens  [Music]  you